hey guys now this video is a lot more
important than you think and it's going
to shock you now most guys these days
are used to taking good care of their
bodies but they don't take care of their
brains which actually control everything
they think and do so in this video i'm
gonna show you eight bad habits that
damage your brain now you need to watch
the video all the way to the end to make
sure that you're not doing any of these
things
let's get to it
[Music]
all right guys now let's start with the
first one
skipping breakfast now this might sound
very strange but it's true a lot of guys
skip their breakfasts including some of
my friends but if you do it it can
damage your brain do you know why people
say that breakfast is the most important
meal of the day well there's a few
reasons why but if you skip your
breakfast and if you do it consistently
it can lower your body's blood sugar
levels and that of course can be very
damaging to your brain cells according
to the science times the brain alone
consumes nearly 20 percent of the total
available glucose in your body which of
course most breakfasts have and without
glucose the brain will not have the
energy to maintain and repair cells
sufficiently and thus the brain will die
at a rapid rate
a lot of people say i don't eat
breakfast if i do it it feels weird
but they're not realizing it's just a
bad habit that they got used to over the
years and here's the thing bad habits
can be replaced by good habits you gotta
start eating your breakfast
smoking now you guys know that i've been
talking about the negative side effects
of smoking on my channel
for a long time and when it comes to
your health we know that it is unhealthy
but it's also unhealthy for your brain
it can damage your brain nicotine
actually shrinks your brain and
according to fermi web in fact brain
shrinkage for a prolonged period can
lead to alzheimer's disease so not only
will you save money when you stop
smoking you'll have white teeth you'll
smell better
[Music]
but you'll also save your brain and stay
smarter for longer
[Music]
loneliness this sounds very strange but
it's true a study at the rush university
medical center in chicago found that
those who had the least social contacts
were suffering from the most severe
cognitive deterioration you know as
humans we are made to connect with one
another and of course there are people
who enjoy their alone time their quiet
time like myself i enjoy to be
alone but there's a limit we are not
made to be alone for a long period of
time and if you are alone go visit some
friends or even better join the club
where you can do something fun like
playing tennis
or fishing
or golf
or join a church group when you go there
most churches are really good friendly
people loving people and they have great
sell groups that you can join in the
week and make some great friends
now you might not be a christian but why
not give it a shot
sitting still for too long
i really mean here sitting on your bum
for too long it's not good for your
health and it's not good for your brain
a new ucla study reports that people who
are more sedentary have thinning in
brain regions linked to memory they say
that even if you do physical activities
is not enough to offset that harmful
effects of just sitting on your bum for
too long so here's my advice when you
sit on your bum and you work for long
hours take 10 minute breaks every now
and then
and walk around a little just get moving
and away from sitting
eating junk food well that's most guys
today right not only is it unhealthy for
your body but it's also really bad for
your brain according to webmd parts of
the brain linked to learning memory and
mental health are smaller in people who
have lots of hamburgers fries potato
chips and soft drinks in their diet
berries whole grains nuts and green
leafy vegetables on the other hand
preserve brain function and slow mental
decline so it's your choice
choose to live unhealthy lifestyle eat
junk food but then you need to accept
the consequences that will come with it
no
respect yourself enough to take good
care of yourself take care of your body
give it what it needs to be healthy
functioning at 100
for years to come
loud music
now this might be a surprise to many of
you
but it is true if you are used to
listening to very loud music especially
with your earphones or headphones you
are damaging your ears and ultimately
your brain if you continue doing it for
too long
according to thebusinessinsider.com
if you consistently blast your music too
loudly you can damage your hearing but
it's not just your ears hearing loss in
older adults is linked to brain problems
such as alzheimer's and loss of brain
tissue
crazy isn't it well all you got to do is
just turn down the volume
not enough sleep again we're talking
about sleep on my channel
man i really hope it's really starting
to sink in how important sleep is for
you not only for your health not only
will it make you tired if you don't
sleep enough but it will also damage
your brain there are many studies on
this the brain purifies itself of toxins
only during the deep sleep cycle lack of
sleep can cause the death of brain cells
which can lead to impaired memory and
reduced abilities
it is the hippocampus that gets the
damage and even just one night of not
sleeping enough
it can influence affect your brain's
ability to remember things to memorize
new information now if you're still
young if you're a student this is very
important listen up it's not a good idea
to be lazy and not study ahead of time
for your exam and then when it's a day
before the exam then you scramble then
you want to study and you study late
into the morning and you don't get
enough sleep then you go and write the
exam with a brain that's not at its
hundred percent you gotta get enough
sleep every night seven to eight hours
overeating now i've already mentioned
eating unhealthy food junk food but if
you overeat is not good for your brain
either and listen carefully even if you
over eat on healthy food
you will get obese and it will cause
things like high blood pressure diabetes
and heart disease and of course all of
this is connected with what
yes with the brain alzheimer's you will
damage your brain
you know
we humans we complain about a lot of
things about
every time we get a health problem we
complain about it but most of the time
it's our own fault we don't take good
care of our bodies
and is the same when it comes to our
soul be honest with yourself and ask
yourself this
are you taking good care
of you or are you just so focused on
this rat race and you just go from one
day to the next you know
there's 150 000 people that die every
single day
you never know when it'll be your time
to move on do you even ask yourself
the most important questions of life
what is your purpose here on earth
where do you really come from and where
will you go when you die
and does god really exist if you want to
know the truth and watch these videos
here from my other channel and i'll see
you there and always remember this
life
is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys